Well, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
Just a reminder to look at the announcements.
We are asking if everybody can schedule their follow any follow up visits if they can do that online at the link.
Actually, this is a hyperlink right there on the announcements to schedule that to just take the pressure off our front desk. We'd appreciate that.
And also right now, I'm saying no Zoom call next week. I'm going to be traveling. I quite possibly will be back.
I might not be back and I hate to, you know, leave people hanging. So right now, I'm going to say no Zoom call next week.
So I just don't know or drive it. So I don't know how that's going to work.
All right, let's jump into the questions. Remember, if you're new, you can chat in a question or you can unmute yourself and ask a question.
If something arises in your hand, let's work on through this.
Okay, first question. I read that if cancer can't feed on glucose and glutamine because you've eliminated it, then cancer is less likely to show up on a CT or PET scan. Is this true?
Well, no, not really because you're never going to eliminate glucose. If you had no glucose circulated in your blood, you would be dead.
So you always have glucose circulated in your blood. Yeah, you're getting rid of simple sugars. You're trying to get your glucose levels down.
But you do a glucose blood test and it's going to be anywhere between 60 and 100 and you still have a glucose level.
Well, I wonder if I never eat any carbohydrates ever again in my life. What if I go on a complete carnivore diet and what if I'm, you know, getting my glucose levels down.
Well, you're never going to get them below 50 and even at that, if you did get them into the 50s and you are anywhere at the age above 30, you're probably at a hypoglycemic state and you could go into a hypoglycemic coma, you can't get zero glucose.
Glutamine the same thing, you're never going to have glutamine. Glutamine is an amino acid. It's essential amino acid. You need it to build other amino acids and other proteins. So you don't ever have zero glutamine.
Now, glutamine is not taken up on a CT scan or PET scan. So you could be eating a ton of glutamine, all the glutamine on the planet and it's never your CT scan or PET scan isn't going to light up any hotter because of your glutamine intake or lack thereup.
There is your glucose, but when you do a PET scan, they give you a glucose syrup so that you will get a brighter positive test. So remember what a PET scan is looking for is highly metabolic activity.
And yes, if you're going to do a PET scan without the prep of a glucose syrup, then it's not an accurate PET scan. So if you're not eating any glucose, let's say you're on a ketogenic diet and your glucose level is as low as it possibly could be, then you're going to do a PET scan. They're still going to give you a glucose syrup before the PET scan. So it's not going to make the PET scan any less accurate.
A CT scan is not at all dependent upon glucose and or glutamine intake or levels or anything. So a CT scan is completely irrelevant to glucose levels or glutamine levels.
So the answer that is that is not true. Next question.
It seems like one of my supplements that I add to my smoothie is causing an odorous gas. I've tried eliminating elimination of ingredients in my smoothie so that it's only frozen strawberries, berries, blueberries, raspberries, water and I assume the supplements, but I still get the gas.
My powdered supplements added are the essential grains and reds, the SBI Pro Plus, the Sun Spectrum and the fermented turmeric ginger and peccasol.
So what is it that could cause gas? I'm assuming that you're getting bodily gas. It's not gas coming out of your blender.
And that was silly. So quite easy. It's the Sun Spectrum. So the Sun Spectrum has fiber in it.
So if a person eats fiber, a fiber product and they get a gassy and they get a stomach issue,
it's because of the fiber. And it's usually a side of small intestinal bacterial overgrowth. So I would say based upon just this information and I would like to talk to you a little bit more probably, but just based upon this information, I would say pause the Sun Spectrum for right now.
Just pause it for a period of time and then see if that changes things. We may need to add a probiotic. We may need to add some buterate, but pause the Sun Spectrum right now based upon this information.
Next question. I read that a strategy if having surgery to reduce the likelihood of cancer spread is to use a statin.
I've read a lot about the negative aspects of statins, especially in regard to having them prescribed for high cholesterol. Have you ever heard of statins being useful?
So there is a book out that is based upon using drugs that are using them in an off label fashion to help people with cancer.
And the use of statins off label for cancer helps with this thing.
Would I ever advise a person who has cancer to go on a statin? So there's a whole bunch of other drugs in this list of this book of using medications off label meaning for purposes other than what they originally created for for helping those with cancer.
What is using metformin? Metformin is something that you'd give to somebody with diabetes and it brings down your glucose levels.
Now that makes all the sense in the world. There really is not a whole lot of negative things to the metformin that using metformin off label to help bring down glucose levels that help to decrease the fuel source for cancer makes a lot of sense.
And there's not a whole lot of drawbacks. Now the only person that I would use that for even with that or I would recommend somebody use that would be somebody who just cannot stick to a diet that's low in glucose or they have when they're going into their cancer they already have a probability of diabetes.
However, the one with statin the only time I would tell a person that has cancer that they should consider using a statin would be if they also had really high cholesterol.
We have a few people with really super high cholesterol made it over 300 and their regular GP has been trying to get them on a statin for a long time and they refuse because there's a lot of negative effects of statin effects your liver etc.
So I'm not a fan of using statins. Again, I can't prescribe them. So I'm just giving you my non medical opinion. I'm not a fan of using statins for cholesterol unless it's seriously high cholesterol.
But if a person has cancer and seriously high cholesterol that I'd say, okay, this is the time where statins can be helpful because it can have some benefits for cancer has a whole bunch of negatives to deliver.
But it can have some benefits to cancer and it can help bring down cholesterol. But if a person is going to do that then they do want to get a comprehensive metabolic panel which includes the liver markers at a fairly regular basis so we could keep an eye on how their liver is working with the statins.
I've read that low dose aspirin could be good for cancer and chemo and he thoughts.
I don't know about this. I don't know about the mechanism of low dose aspirin and chemo. I think the thought process with the mechanism of action is that it's a blood thinner and it can open up the channels in a cell that's the stock process.
Whether it actually opens up channels in a in a cancer cell so that that chemo will be better absorbed in the cancer cell. I don't know.
If you're doing a low dose like a baby aspirin there's not a ton of negative effects to that so it's certainly I wouldn't think it could be could be harmful.
So that's something it's like it's like the idea of taking with breast cancer patients especially to take an over the counter anti histamine.
There's not a ton of negative effects of that type of a drug a low dose baby aspirin. There's not a ton of negative effects of that.
It can be worth exploring.
I've read that Ben Fultamine which is a is a synthetic thiamine so you know that's a synthetic B1 and alpha and R alpha opeoc acid which is an antioxidant would be good to combat peripheral neuropathy a side effect of chemo any truth to that any other things to try.
There is truth to that so you can get and pull and pull to mean in its own form typically the doses you take about 300 to 600 milligrams of it.
I remember correctly.
Now typically people with peripheral neuropathy we give them a whole food organic B1 B6 but that's a much lower dose.
There has been some studies with the synthetic thiamine B1 helpful for that we haven't used it a lot but I have a number of patients that are doing that.
The alpha opeoc acid I think I would stay away from right now when you're dealing with when you have active cancer but dealing with the side effects of chemo using a B1 a B6 also.
And the synthetic B1 which I'm not a fan of synthetic supplements but it's the only way to get that high enough dose of thiamine in it.
It certainly can be used if you could certainly try it there's I haven't read any downsides to it so I believe my recommended foods list states that soy is okay but it has to be fermented that is miso etc.
When soy milk be recommended at all no so soy milk is not fermented so there's a difference between fermented soy and regular soy.
So regular soy even if it's organic soy that's not fermented acts as an estrogenic and it increases the bad estrogens in your body so you should everybody should stay away from soy.
Everyone male female whether you have cancer or don't have cancer we are getting way too many exogenous estrogens in the environment.
And that is a big driver for all sorts of you know ill health not just cancer but certainly if you have any hormone related cancer it's even worse for that person.
Now fermented soy works differently there's only a few sources of fermented soy that are supplemental in highland 951 is one of them that's a liquid product that tastes horror but it's a fermented soy specifically made for cancer patients.
Or using some of the Japanese fermented soy foods can be helpful that's a fermented soy too it's very acquired taste for those foods but eating those fermented soy foods on a regular basis has the same effect.
For a fermented soy helps dislodge estrogen the bad estrogen that attaches to the estrogen eight or receptor or that was called the estrogen made a receptor now.
The cell membrane which blocks a poptosis that helps dislodge that bad estrogen so fermented soy actually is a good thing.
But for soy that is not fermented is not a good thing so the only fermented soy would be those Japanese soy type products that are food based products that have a very distinct taste that you need to acquire a taste of that.
I could eat just about anything but I can't eat that it's just horrible or a product called highland 951 which is a liquid based product.
That's another we have a number of people number of our patients that are taken highland 951.
Yeah so you can't have soy milk.
My protocol states to limit gluten how often would that mean you could have gluten in a week so far just limited.
Well you're always better just to limit 80 to because it's so inflammatory but if gluten is not a main driver and it's just says to limit gluten.
You know I would never I would never want to say to a person that you've already eliminated it to say go back go ahead and go back and eat it once a week or something because it's much better for you not just for the cancer but for your brain.
To keep to continue to eliminate it because gluten is so inflammatory to your brain and to your thyroid gland it's just anything else so if you've already eliminated I'd say just stay on the elimination part.
But to somebody else who's though I eat gluten every day you said to stop eating gluten said to limit it was that mean can I just have one you think a day no it means you can maybe try to drop down the one thing a week and then one take every couple weeks
if you're trying to get that out if you're diet.
Why does my protocol include the fermented tuberic and ginger and not your product curcuclear how do they differ?
I saw a number of places on your website where you recommend the curcuclear.
So the curcuclear is one of the better curcumids on the market.
But when I test a person I have a lot of people take it curcuclear and I have a lot of people take it the fermented tuberic and ginger.
It just depends on how they test with the cheek swap test.
So some people just test better with the whole food fermented tuberic and some people taste test better on the curcuclear.
It just depends on the cheek swap test. That's the only difference there.
So it just depends on that.
Well we are cruising through the questions so if you guys have some questions you better start thinking about them.
I'm really struggling with weakness.
I seem to need to eat every two hours.
I am nausea for about 10 days after my first chemo and lost some weight.
I've now been able to eat better and have gained a bit back a little of that back.
I've also tried to up by complex carbohydrates.
I purchased a glucometer and we'll start using that shortly.
So remember when you do the glucometer just test it in the morning before you eat.
And then if you can send me those readings, e-mail me those readings to labs at cuttersclinic.com.
I would like that.
Another note, sign note, sorry, but some people send labs or something to labs at cuttersclinic.
They don't put their name.
So I can't recognize you based upon your e-mail.
So please just finish the e-mail with just your signature.
Most people do that but some people don't.
It's like who is this?
I have to look at the lab to see even who it is.
So please do that. It would help.
So send me those glucometer readings that you're more in glucometer readings.
That would be helpful.
Could something else be causing this weakness?
I wanted to fast 24 hours before chemo next Tuesday and 24 hours after.
But I'm worried it won't be able to.
My first chemo I fasted about 10 hours before is fasting before and after chemo.
That helpful.
Well, fasting before chemo is more important than fasting after the chemo.
So I would say, you know, if you could fast, you know, 10 plus hours prior to chemo,
that's going to, and then when you're done with chemo just go ahead and eat something.
You know, that's the more important thing is getting a fast in before the chemo.
The weakness is caused from the chemo.
So chemo is going to remember chemo is highly oxidative.
Which means it's poisonous to cancer cells.
But chemo unlike other therapies like B17 and things like that that are oxidative.
chemo was poisonous to healthy cells too.
So you get a lot of cell die off.
You're going to get a lot of cell lysis.
That means you're going to overwhelm your liver pathways.
That means you're just going to feel fatigued.
That is what is also called a Herk Simon reaction.
When you're getting a lot of endotoxins, cell particles die off.
And then your body has to get rid of them.
How do you get rid of them?
It goes into your bloodstream and it has to go through your liver.
And you have to get rid of this and you could just overwhelm it.
So some of the things that you can help with that is a couple days after the,
right after the chemo you can put a hot pad over your liver.
You can do castor oil packs over your liver.
And then 48 hours after the chemo start to eat coffee.
And it was even a couple of days that will really help get your liver flowed
and get rid of the endotoxins.
So that will help a lot with the weakness.
The other thing that could cause weakness is ademia.
So looking at your blood work.
Let's take another look at that and see where you're at with ademia.
Whether you're a red blood cell is, are being affected negatively.
And you're getting an ademia.
Now you're going to have weakness and tiredness with low white blood cells,
which, which chemo is going to produce on everybody as well.
And then let's look at your, let's look at the glucometer.
If your blood glucose is getting too low, like the question before,
we talked about you could have some hypoglycemia.
That's going to give you some tiredness and weakness.
So let's look at all those things.
Those are the things that I would look at.
I would say it's pretty normal for a person to feel that way.
Post chemo.
But then you go, okay, well, what is the exact mechanism?
How can I try to call back that?
So these are really, really good questions to ask.
I had metabolic testing done.
This person had blood testing done.
Should I be concerned about the following changes?
Glucose 112 up from 91.
I'm on a low sugar diet.
Just fruit.
And diet has not changed.
What all depends on whether that glucose test was fasting or not.
So if this blood test wasn't fasting, then we just throw that number out.
If it was fasting, yes, I was doing a, I did a 12 hour fast.
It's like I always do it.
My glucose is up to 112.
Then yeah, that is a concern.
I don't know what is causing your glucose to be up to 112.
Now usually glucose is elevated due to diet.
But glucose can also be elevated over time due to just damage to cell membranes.
No one really relate to any supplements or anything you're taking.
But you know, that can happen as we age two.
So we'd want to know if that's fast, eat or not.
Again, if it's, oh, I did it fast before this test because didn't say I needed to.
Well, then you just throw that number out.
Forget about glucose.
Globulent now.
I would have range at 2.1.
So as globulent is low, globulent is a protein from the liver.
And globulent will be low with cancer patients.
So will it get lower if the cancer is growing?
Yes, and no.
Usually, globulent is one of the first things you find out before a person even has a diagnosis of cancer.
Their globulent levels are low.
That's what's called an albedist side.
When you look at somebody's, they don't know where they have cancer.
And you get, you do their blood test and their globulent levels are low.
So you could also get low globulent from just immune insufficiencies.
If your immune system is, is being stressed from, you have a chronic infection
or a mood disorder or toxicity, things like that can affect globular levels.
Heavy metal toxicity or chemical toxicity can cause low globular levels.
So those are all things that can decrease your globular levels.
So, boo, would any of your supplement changes cause that?
No, no, I would say no.
I mean, it is a concern.
Where is my cancer at?
Is my cancer getting worse with a globulent going down?
It really depends on what the drop was.
The EGFR is the estimated glomerular filtration rate.
And you want that much higher.
Now that dropping from 94 to 67 is a concern because that tells us that there may be some stress on the kidneys.
And the CO2 levels.
So looking at the kidneys would be something you want to make sure that a person isn't dehydrated.
Are you drinking enough water?
Are we able to flush the kidneys well enough?
Those are things that you're concerned with with glomerular filtration rate.
Your CO2 levels drop in.
CO2 levels can be low with what's called metabolic acidosis.
That's where you have more acid in tissues.
That can be from all lots of different things.
That's the most commonly from a poor diet.
But we want to look at other issues with that.
Metabolic consequences of CO2 levels can be because of low.
So CO2 is a measure of my carbonate in the blood.
So low by carbonate in the blood can be partially due to issues with stomach acid too.
And respiratory alkalosis, if a person has any long issues, those can be CO2 level imbalances.
So we want to look at the big picture of all that.
MCV up from 1.98 to 100 at MCHC changing.
Those are, you can just throw those out.
Those are within normal ranges of dysfunction there.
You've got a pair of clear black sand blood root and urevent for three weeks.
Still taking high dose fenmenazole and Ivermectin with milk distal from a previous protocol.
Can these changes, here's your question, can these changes be due to a parasite detox?
Maybe if a person has liver flux, this could be an issue.
The struggle with liver flux, I don't even think that they're measured on most the parasite testing.
So that could be a piece of that.
So I know we have some labs to go over with you with parasite testing.
So we'll talk more about this when we go over those labs.
Is there a possibility that I would need to have my rife light checked?
The reason I'm asking is last week, one night, during the night,
when I was repositioned the light, it crackled and sparked a bit.
I just wondered if I might need a checkup.
Maybe I don't know.
If it's working, just find out and you haven't had any issues with it since,
then I would say I would just keep going with it.
I wouldn't, I'd be careful where I'm position it that I'm not pulling on the cord.
If I ain't on the cord and affect the gas in there and it's just sparked
because of the frequencies going through there, that's possibility.
So it could be literally nothing.
I just be careful that it's stable during the night and you're not rolling over
and begging it or something like that.
If it's working now, I would let it, I would continue to use it.
I would necessarily be concerned.
Can you go over COVID supplement recommendations that folks should have on hand?
First of all, I'm not really concerned about COVID any longer.
But there's all sorts of different diseases that may be coming our way
that may be implemented by powers that be that want to make a sick.
So what are some things that we should have on hand for that?
I think having Iverbacked on hand, having antibiotics on hand,
would be a really wise thing to have on hand
and you can order different antibiotics and different in Iverbacked,
just to have in your medicine cabinet so that you have access to things like that
and then having a lot of nutrition to deal with infections.
We have a product line called professional formulas that I really like
because they're really into homeopaths for all sorts of different things.
We have homeopaths for H1N1, homeopaths for all sorts of weird diseases
that could be helpful to have on hand.
They may be impossible to get.
I know the FDA came after this company during COVID
because they didn't want anybody supplying anything that was going to help people with anything.
So the FDA came after us during COVID for selling fed vendors all
and pushing the Joe Tippen's protocol.
We got a nine page letter from the FDA demanding CSIN assist,
you know, to assist her everything about Joe Tippen's protocol
get everything off our website or they're going to sue the bananas on of us
and we had to comply.
You know, so it's just the powers that be do not want us to stay healthy
so having things on hand would be wise.
Having fed vendors all on hand would be wise.
You know, those are good things to be prepared for.
You know, now we're in a time where, okay, nothing's happening.
That's really great.
But if something happens, it could happen very quickly
and we could be in a bad situation.
Next question.
Are there options for dealing with leaky gut since repair invite is not recommended
because of the algalutamine in this product?
Repair invite is a product by a company called apex energetics
and we don't sell it and we don't recommend it to any cancer patients
because it's very high glutamine content.
Now most gut healing products, gut healing nutritional products
are going to have glutamine in it.
So most of them are kind of off the table for cancer patients.
But a lot of the ingredients in gut healing products can be gotten,
you know, by themselves too.
One product that we use a lot of and I really think that it's a great product
is the GI soothe.
The GI soothe is a product by zymogen.
It's a little chocolate flavored little capsule that you just suck on.
And the idea is that, you know, we always think that healing
our gut has to be weighed out in the gut, but healing the gut starts
through the throat actually in our stomach.
So GI soothe you just suck on it.
It's got marshmallow, it's not marshmallows like what you'd roast
but it's the marshmallow herb, it's got slippery elm,
and it's got licorice extract which are three great gut healing things.
They're all three of those things are in the product that you just named.
So RepairVite has algorithmine, marshmallow, slippery elm,
a bunch of other different things, but you can get those things separate too.
So certainly you could make it a point where we go over some ideas if that's the issue.
But just starting with GI soothe taking a couple of those a day,
they're chocolate flavored.
It's not just for kids because they're chewables for adults
because it helps heal, starting in the throat and in the stomach,
but all the way down.
GI soothe is the product name.
Okay, next question from the chat.
You mentioned last week applying iodide topically on breast tumor
but didn't say what this would do.
Beneficial, if you're trying to prevent eruption,
is a beneficial trying to prevent eruption,
my tumor seems to have constant small scab
and it itches like a healing cut.
Not sure if it's a side of slow eruption or not,
best recommendation for preventing eruption.
So what I use iodide topically if I haven't,
if I have a scab, yes, maybe.
So my idea of using iodide topically would be mainly for antiseptic.
So I don't think I'd necessarily use it topically if I wasn't,
you know, if having any type of infection,
even cross my mind.
And that's the same thing with using hydrogen peroxide.
And the benefit of hydrogen peroxide is that it is highly
coated as a great topical antiseptic
because the hydrogen peroxide is a oxidizing agent
it kills bacteria and the virus is very quickly and very easily.
But because it's an oxidizing agent,
if you had an open wound, it could help kill the cancer in there too.
So I would rather have you use a hydrogen peroxide.
It has both benefits of an antiseptic,
killing any infectious organism,
and the possibility of killing a cancer.
So will it prevent an eruption?
Well, we can't say that.
I don't know anything that's going to,
quote unquote, prevent an eruption.
But I would use, I would lead towards using hydrogen peroxide.
Next question.
I saw a consumer report study of 23 protein powder shakes.
And many were found to be high in lead.
How could you test to see if your lead levels are high?
I'm using your recommended protein powder in chia pudding.
Now that's a really interesting question
because I, my daughters are very into natural healing
in my one daughter who works with me is a chiropractor.
And my other daughters have been into all natural healing things as well.
And my one daughter has followed this lead mama or whatever she calls herself
on Facebook or Instagram or something like that.
And because her son or something,
the story goes had issues with, with lead.
And because of those issues with lead has been kind of a guru
in testing everything for lead.
Now the positives and negatives of that is that you can become obsessed
with that.
No, if you have had an issue with lead that you're obsessed with
with not being exposed to any lead.
Now the truth is is that even if you are exposed to lead,
it doesn't mean that you are going to absorb lead.
There is lead in our environment.
There's lead in the soil.
So there is lead in literally every vegetable that you eat.
You have lead.
One of the tests that we do on you is the metals test.
So if we didn't get your metals test back,
we'll see the metals test whether you have lead or not.
All the years I've done this,
and all the years that we've talked about heavy metal toxicity
and heavy metal toxicity is a huge thing and it is a big thing.
The amount of people that actually have heavy metal toxicity
is so small that you have to understand.
So we're exposed to heavy metals.
You're exposed to mercury.
You're exposed to lead.
There's more mercury in fish because of coal burning power plants.
There's so you're eating fish that has mercury.
There's more mercury in our food supply because of coal burning power plants.
So we're exposed to more mercury there.
There's lead in our food.
There's lead in our water.
There's lead in our lead pipes.
There's lead in our things.
But the truth is why do more people have lead toxicity?
Because you don't have absorption sites for those things.
So you will absorb them if you have leaky gut.
That's why you want to be working on your gut.
That's why I got most of you guys on gut healing things as well.
Because if you will absorb things that you shouldn't absorb if you have a leaky gut.
But even if you did absorb excess lead from something you are exposed to,
your liver should get rid of it.
So it's not.
Remember your level of toxicity is equal to the amount of toxin that you are exposed to,
consume, absorb.
See the amount of absorbed toxin minus that which you get rid of.
Equals that which is left over in you.
So that's what you want to measure.
What do I have in me?
So we do your intestine measure.
But I'm trying to excrete.
Okay.
I have high levels of lead.
Then we want to address that.
So is there is there lead in protein powders?
Well, probably because protein powders are either made out of animal tissue
or they're made out of vegetable tissue, which has lead in it.
So does that mean I should not eat protein powders?
No.
The thing that you want to be concerned with with cancer patients is,
I want to have a protein powder that is relatively lower in glutamine.
That's my concern with a protein powder.
If you want to measure the land content of the lettuce that you're eating,
or the hamburger that you're eating,
or whatever food that you're eating even in an organic source,
there's going to be some lead content.
And that's my argument against the lead mama that's out there,
is that the ridiculousness of being so anal about something that you are not supposed to even absorb.
Number one, and if you do absorb it, you're supposed to excrete it.
Why don't you instead measure that person, whether they have levels of lead in their body?
And then you know whether you need to be more anal about stayed away from lead.
So if I don't have any heavy metal toxicity in my body,
then okay, that's something I can leave off the table and not worry about heavy metal toxicity.
But let's say I have really horrible glyphosate toxicity, for example.
So then I need to be more diligent to look at my sources of glyphosate.
So if you measure what's going on with you, then you could look at,
okay, then what do I need to concentrate on?
Otherwise you're going to drive yourself crazy, right?
Because you can't just stay away from everything.
You're going to be out of this world completely.
We're not supposed to be out of this world completely.
We can't be out of this world completely.
It's not even possible.
So you know, even if you moved up to a glacier and you know,
there's still toxins that are probably in that glacial water you're drinking.
So it's just not even possible.
So it's better to measure you and let's see what do I need to personally stay away from?
It's partly because maybe I'm exposed to more, let's say I had eye glyphosate.
This is an example is maybe because I had more exposure to glyphosate.
So I need to be more diligent stay away from foods with glyphosate.
Or it's quite possibly or a combination of that.
I just don't get rid of glyphosate very well.
I need to be more diligent stay away from glyphosate and supporting those pathways
because I don't get rid of it very well.
That's why I have high levels of glyphosate or at least part of that.
So better to measure the person, I wouldn't be concerned about the protein powders
that are high in lead per se because you could literally,
and these tests can seem a report test.
Yeah, I just don't buy all that stuff because it's just a sampling and it can be way off.
So I know that people mean well, like that lead mama leads well.
But I also know that it can make people just live in fear.
And we're not supposed to live in fear.
We're supposed to live in wisdom.
We're supposed to look at these things, but we're not supposed to live in fear.
I think the way you do that is you measure your old body.
And what do I need to deal with and what do I need to be wise about?
And I'd be fearful of the world.
Everything in the world will be in a boogie band.
So that's my thought.
Next question.
I've been trying to cold shower after a sauna for a benefit of herbedic stress.
But I hate it.
And I feel like my brain just screams at me to get out.
It this seems like it's stimulating my central or my synthetic nervous system.
Can you explain her reconcile and see me paradox between the herbedic stress and stimulating one's sympathetic nervous system?
Yeah, I'm not a fan of doing a cold.
I've never done a cold shower.
Honestly, I've never done a cold shower after a sauna.
I hate it.
It does stress me out as well.
When I do a sauna, I just I take a nice warm shower and relax.
And I think that your parasympathetic response is much more important than any other herbedic effect.
But I think everybody's different.
Some people do love doing cold plunges.
Some people love doing that kind of stuff.
I don't.
And if you don't love doing that, it is going to have a sympathetic nervous system response.
You're going to have a lighter fight response.
And it's totally negating everything that you're trying to do.
So I would agree with you.
I am not a fan of doing that.
And you have to do what's right for you.
Next question.
Do you have hyperbactin and fed bed dissolve available on the store?
If not, what's a good source?
We have fed bed dissolve.
We have fed bed dissolve on the store that you could purchase.
But we can't legally sell the hyperbactin.
But I do have a source of hyperbactin that I put on the home page of the member site.
And that is a good source because I ordered it from them.
And I got it.
You always worried about source when you order something and you never receive it, right?
And they're from some country in Europe that who knows.
But no, I got it within a couple of weeks.
And it was a good source of hyperbactin.
So that's the link that I put on the home page of the member site.
That's where I bought my hyperbactin from.
They had like by three bottles.
Get two free or something like that.
So I got five bottles of 12 milligram hyperbactin.
And the fed bed is all on our store.
Oh, somebody asked the same question.
Where can we get real hyperbactin we can trust?
And then what is lactate dehydrogenase?
So lactate dehydrogenase is a protein marker that is given off when there's tissue destruction.
A lot of blood tests will call it LD.
A lot of blood tests will call it LDH.
LDH I think was the old name for it.
I still go by LDH, but I did most of the water labs call it LD.
So LD or LDH, which a lab calls it, is a measurement of tissue destruction.
So it can be a tumor marker test.
So if I have, you know, let's say I have breast cancer,
and I have, you know, the cancer is growing and there's tissue destruction,
then my LDH levels will possibly be elevated.
So it can tell us that.
But can also measure tissue destruction of other things.
It's not discriminated to just breast cancer or any cancer.
So LD is one of those things that they measure.
Let's say if you had this horrible chest pain, you felt like an elephant was standing out of your chest.
You, you know, you rushed to the hospital thinking you had a heart attack.
LDH is one of the things that they measure.
And that would be what they come into.
They have blood tests. The doctor comes in.
I'm sorry, but I think you had a heart attack.
Well, how do you know you didn't do an EKG yet?
You didn't do a scan yet?
How do you know how to add a heart attack?
Because you had elevated LDH.
And that means you had some tissue destruction.
And with given all your symptoms, it's most likely a heart attack we need to do further tests.
So it just is a measurement of a protein that will be given off in any tissue destruction.
Could be elevated if you had a horrible, horrible car accident or something like that.
You're going to have tissue destruction.
So it's not going to be specific to a cancer or to cancer.
But if a person had no other problems and they had a spike in LDH.
And most likely it would coordinate with a spike in other tumor markers.
But I still, and it's still considered as a tumor marker because of that.
The other questions.
No?
Well, thank you very much.
Probably won't talk next week.
So if you jumped out of this late, it will probably will not be having a Zoom call next week.
Whoever it is, it will be on the member site.
So if you jumped out of this late, I will be traveling next week.
It probably won't be home for the Zoom call.
So I'm just saying no Zoom call right now.
And then the number one thing is I announced last week.
If you want to schedule a coaching call.
Remember the prices that have gone down to $85 for a call with me.
But we are asking that you start scheduling online instead of calling in.
That helps us a lot.
So thank you so much.
Everybody have a blessed day.
And we will not see you next week.
Probably, but we'll talk the week after that.
All right.
Bye bye everybody.